for joining us from Los Angeles with
more on the corona virus outbreak is CBS
News medical contributor dr. David agus
David good morning good morning I have
to start out with this I've spoken to
people who are either in a dead panic or
who say simply that we the media are
blowing this out of proportion which is
it you know there's no question that
most people in the United States if they
do get this virus and a good portion
will will survive and will not get that
sick the problem is we have to protect
the elderly and the people with other
medical conditions because it all
happens at once it will overwhelm our
medical system and there will be
thousands and thousands the deaths that
we don't need so we have to put in these
you know precautions and we have to be
aggressive now so that it doesn't happen
doctor one of the things that's
difficult here is how general the
symptoms can be so for all the people
asking or wondering right now who are
concerned what when is it time for
someone a friend a family acquaintance
anyone else to see the doctor it's a
great question Jeff I mean anybody who
has mild symptoms now should self
quarantine that is stay home and wait
till the symptoms go away and when
you're a day free you can go back out
and you know the problem is if we all
went to the doctor now and we have any
runny nose in the middle of flu season
we would overwhelm and then you sit in
the waiting room with a hundred other
people who are coughing if you didn't
have it going in you will going out so
you know when you have symptoms that are
serious or you're starting to really
worry then you should call your doctor
and go to the medical system but
otherwise try to self quarantine we've
heard a lot about people that are more
at risk and the CDC issued some new
guidelines for some of those what have
we seen as far as changes in that regard
well you know yesterday the CDC said hey
listen elderly people do not leave your
home as much as possible you know don't
go out to places with large people it
would large numbers of people getting
together and you know I think they're
right I think we have to be cautious for
people who are at risk so if you are
older six seventh eighth generation 80s
you probably shouldn't get on planes you
shouldn't go into areas you know large
malls and large areas where people are
congregate
because it's too high a risk you know
what we're seeing is that people who are
younger have mild symptoms and starting
mid-50s it starts to get worse and worse
and David along those lines for people
that are washing hands and using
antibacterial gels is that actually
working at this point do we know the
bottom line is we know so little about
this virus you know the best way to
fight a virus and to stop a pandemic
from spreading is to have tests and to
have knowledge and our response was very
delayed here so washing the hands
critical soap or antibacterial washes
you know don't touch your face all the
things you're told can help but if
somebody coughs or you know there's
particles in the air and you cannot stop
that by any measures so many regards is
be careful where you are and where you
go especially if you're high risk we
learned David last night that 900
thousand tests have been shipped out and
there are more to come are we making
enough progress on that front now we're
not there yet
you know I'm hearing over and over again
from medical centers across and
governors are calling me saying we don't
have the tests we need so tests were
shipped out and realized that it's
multiple tests per person the initial
test is two swabs and then we repeat it
many times several times so 900,000 test
doesn't equal 900,000 individual
patients we need it more in the country
we need the infrastructure to do the
testing because it's not there also you
can ship a larger number of tests but
unless you have people trained in
equipment to do it it's not going to be
well implemented you know over the next
several weeks that'll happen but it
certainly is weeks late to stop the
spread of this they're going to be an
enormous increase in the number of cases
in the United States when we do more
testing doctor beyond getting those
testing kits out there's eight point
three billion dollar spending bill that
was signed by the president yesterday
how else should that money be used to
fight corona virus well much of that
money is used for future research
developing future vaccines understanding
the virus better but we need leadership
and we need to develop new ways of doing
testing you know in Korea they do
drive-through testing so you can imagine
you don't feel well you get in your car
you go somebody in a spacesuit swab you
go home a couple hours later you get
called and told your result in the
United
you go to an emergency room and you wait
three-and-a-half hours while everyone is
coughing around you you get your result
we need to develop infrastructure here
in the United States to do things better
all right dr. David agus thank you